as governor of New York I am asking
healthcare professionals across the
country if you don't have a health care
crisis in your community please come
help us in New York now we need relief
we need relief for nurses who are
working 12-hour shifts one after the
other after the other we need relief for
doctors we need relief for attendants so
if you're not busy come help us
please and we will return the favor
we will return the favor New York yes we
have it now intensely there will be a
curve New York at one point will be on
the other side of the curve and then
there will be an intense issue somewhere
else in the nation and the New York way
is to be helpful so help New York we're
the ones who are hit now that's today
but tomorrow it's going to be somewhere
else
whether it's Detroit whether it's New
Orleans it will work its way across the
country and this is the time for us to
help one another